[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hi my name is brian wood i'm the
technical communications and outreach
manager here at wolfram
uh today i'm talking with jesse friedman
software engineer
who has been working on remote batch
computation in the wolfram language
um so jesse just kind of give me a
summary what exactly
is meant by remote batch computation and
why is it important
right well i guess we can we can break
uh remote batch computation down well
you know what computation is we can
break it down into into two words remote
meaning that it's taking place somewhere
other than your local computer
and uh batch meaning that uh in um
in contrast to uh to the normal
interactive computation that you might
do day to day in in mathematica using
the wolfram language
um it's it's not something where you're
you're hitting shift enter and you're
getting a
result immediately or a few seconds
later uh we're submitting something that
gets run
asynchronously somewhere else uh and
then later we check on it to see if it's
uh if it's if the computation has
completed and and to retrieve the
results
and this is actually really powerful
when you're running um long-running
uh computation something that might take
a couple hours or or even a couple days
uh you don't have to worry about your
computer staying on
um or or uh if you're if you're using
mathematica if you're running a
if you do shift enter evaluation it's
gonna block the um
uh block the the main thread so you
can't do any other computations
at the same time you don't have to worry
about that because it's it's running
somewhere else and you just have a a
reference to it somehow to to go and
retrieve the results uh later on
right on that makes total sense so so
this is mainly
probably for larger computations and
things like you're talking about where
it might not be convenient to have it
running locally for
however long it takes for that
computation to run
uh absolutely yeah the examples that
we're going to go over are on the
smaller scale just uh
just because we we don't have uh hours
to uh to record this
um but uh but yeah in in in reality it
it's
uh the the the kind of scale at which uh
this remote batch computation to make
sense is when you have
jobs when you have code uh that that
takes hours uh might take hours or
um or longer to run or if you might have
something that um
that actually runs relatively quickly
but you want to take advantage of
compute resources that you don't have
locally like being able to run in the
cloud on
on dozens and dozens of cpus uh
simultaneously
which is something that a lot of us
don't have access to on our own local
machines
sure sure yeah it's uh it's a lot
different from trying to run
something say on a laptop where you're
sort of limited by the the computational
power so um
uh so yeah let's why don't we go ahead
and dive in you can um
start showing us some of the examples um
and i'll probably have a couple
questions along the way
um so uh so are the remote batch
computation
uh functionality that's uh coming in
version uh 12.2 um
has two two main there are two main
functions with which you you interact
with it there's one called remote batch
submit
and one called remote batch map submit
so we'll we'll look at remote batch
submit uh
first um so the the structure of this um
of the remote batch computation system
of remote batch submit and friends
uh is that we're we're interacting with
a uh what we're calling what we call a
remote batch computation provider
a provider like amazon aws um
through a aws service called aws batch
which is oriented specifically towards a
batch computation
we also support another provider called
uh called charity engine
which i'll show a very brief example of
later on
um so the first thing i have to do here
is create a remote batch submission
environment so this is an object it's
really just a data structure that
um that represents contains a few bits
of information that
the wolfram language needs in order to
submit your job so
on aws batch this this information is a
job queue
a job definition and an amazon s3 bucket
uh to store uh input and output data in
so these are things these are resources
that exist in your aws account so you
put in here the um
uh the the uh identifier of the job
queue and of the job definition that um
uh that you have created in your account
that you want to use and
we're going to have documentation of
course on on how to create uh these
things
and how to get yourself up and running
with um with aws batch uh
for the first time um so i already have
mine which um
this is my information here and i get
this uh this object here but what's
important is that
it's gotten stored in this variable so i
can then use it later
um so this example i'm going to do i
just have i have this image
um uh which is a uh example image that's
included in
um uh in mathematica it's an ocelot it's
in black and white
uh yes very absolutely classic um so i
have
and i i have this function here tint
image which just tints uh the image
using a color um
a color hue from zero uh zero to one so
it
it rotates the uh the well it tints the
image with a uh with a given hue
um so here i'm i'm i'm using hue 0.5 it
could be anywhere from
uh from zero which is red to one which
is also red so it's like rotating around
a circle
um uh so have this the tint image
function and i'm also just
resizing it uh uh so it's uh smaller
just so
because i'm gonna create a couple of
them so i don't i don't want the
output to be super big although it could
be the system can of course handle that
um so now i'm going to use the remote
batch submit function the first argument
is that environment that we created up
above
um and then the second argument is the
code that you want to run
and uh we've designed the system we've
tried to make it um
as simple as possible to integrate
existing wolfram language code use it
you have it running locally
now you want to run it in the cloud on
on aws batch
so this is a piece of code that i could
just uh take here i'm going to
not use parallel table so i don't have
to start all my kernels but i could run
this locally
just fine um and i could run parallel
table just fine too
um but so all i have to do is wrap this
this little bit of code in remote batch
submit and
now it's magically it gets run uh in my
computation environment
uh on in the cloud and i'm also
specifying here that i want
um i want aws batch to give me uh to
give uh
for make make available to my job uh
for virtual cpus basically for cpu cores
so this parallel table um uh call here
will run on four cpus
so i'll go ahead and run this this uh
will take 30 years
or 60 seconds to um for the job to
actually get get scheduled and
start running so uh so yeah we'll uh
we'll we'll let that go any
um any questions i guess uh sure so
i guess uh you say that you're using
parallel table there i
i am assuming that that means pretty
much any of the parallel
uh functionality that's available in
wolfram language can be
sort of sent offloaded onto one of those
aws servers and it'll it'll
just work the same way as the parallel
function normally would in your
local notebook yep absolutely the kernel
that runs uh
in on aws on ec2 is is the same thing
that the same kernel the same wolfram
language kernel that you're running
locally so
any basically anything you can do
locally works should work pretty much
fine
uh in the uh in the cloud um as long as
of course the parallel functionality
is not very useful if you only give one
vcpu
to your job but as uh as long as you
your job has enough vcpus and has enough
memory
uh to run to run the code that you've
given it you can do
just about anything that you can you can
do locally
so is there any kind of upper limit on
the number of cpus you can set aside or
does that set depend on your aws
subscription or
i'm not an aws user myself so
yeah that's that's a good question uh
the limit is basically um
the uh the uh the
basically the largest instance that uh
that ec2 amazon
g2 has available and the the largest
general purpose uh use instance
that they have right now has 96 uh vcpus
uh so that's basically the um the limit
with uh remote batch submit
although with remote batch submit i'm
sorry with remote batch map submit which
we'll see a little bit later you can
you can you can go uh above that using a
uh a different method of
um of job parallelization can imagine
imagine a world where you need
more than 96 cpus to deal with yeah
um that's yeah so that's pretty pretty
amazing really
um so this seems like this is sort of
built for
people who are already using some cloud
provider
um can you can you speak to sort of how
this compares
with uh for instance just the regular
cloud evaluate or cloud submit types of
things that that are
also built into the wolfram language oh
yeah that's that's a good question
um cloud evaluate and cloud submit are
all functions and
things like that cloud deploy et cetera
are all functions that interact with the
wolfram cloud which is right
which is a a service that we will from
research
provide as a as a product as a
subscription
um and uh evaluations that you run there
run on our uh
that is wolfram research's uh servers
right um
while uh so uh so when you're when
you're using the wolfram cloud you're
you're you're basically paying for the
time on our servers in addition to
um to the the uh the
i guess the license to the uh to the uh
the product that you're using anyways um
but on on aws you uh
the only thing that you're that you're
paying for when you run on aws
is the the license the wolfram language
the mathematical license that
that you end up uh that you're that you
use um you're not paying for
um uh or rather you're not paying us for
the
uh the infrastructure the uh the
instances the
um the the hardware the servers um
that you're that you're using you're
paying aws for that so you can make use
of
of uh whatever like if your organization
already uses aws and already has
billing set up um and maybe maybe has
some uh some
discount plans in place because you can
uh there are things like that available
for ec2 you can make use of all of that
and
you basically have the choice of the
cloud provider that you want to run with
you can use aws
you can use charity engine and we're
planning to add in the future support
for uh
for google cloud and uh and uh microsoft
azure
very cool okay here so it looks like uh
this this job has uh has just finished
um and you noticed that it did take an
awful lot longer than it did when i ran
it uh locally
um a minute ago that's because as i
mentioned there is some latency
inherent latency involved in submitting
this job to um
to aws so the actual code ran just as
quick as it did
locally or perhaps even faster because
it was uh in parallel
um but there's this latency which is a
constant basically a constant involved
in
in this case um it's uh it's about uh
seemed like it was about a minute and a
half
uh but remember since this is really
intended for running multi-hour
uh computations or at least that's where
that's where the advantage really really
really shows uh having an extra minute
uh or so of latency
uh on top of uh on top of your
evaluation uh really
doesn't matter at all when you're when
you're running on that sort of scale
um so we sorry we saw i evaluated this
and
so this this uh went and uh and
downloaded the job
output from uh for the from the s3
bucket that it was stored in
and uh and it is it's a wolf language
list here i can do anything i could
normally do with a with a with a list uh
uh using it
um so now it's back in the wolfram
language locally and you can manipulate
it however you need
uh whatever you the next step in your in
your project is you have this
uh this output and you can use it cool
okay so uh i'll go on to
uh remote uh batch maps a bit but if
that's okay um
so this is uh this is um
this is this is interesting it uh it
sometimes uh sometimes it's a little
difficult to understand at first
what this is doing um so i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna run it and then
and then explain then explain what uh
what is done
uh uh afterwards um
so i'll just get these this
visualization is i think helpful for
um for explaining um so
so what i'm doing here um this is
basically the syntax here is essentially
the same as the wolfram language
function map
which is which iterates a function
whether it be a pure function or a
named function uh over the elements uh
of a list
um and there's another function called
parallel map which is which has the same
syntax as map and is often used for um
for parallel computations it just splits
up the list across uh
multiple cores and runs uh parts of the
list on
on on each each of your cpu cores so as
if you have a
80 element list and 80 cores it runs 10
elements
more or less on each on each core so it
runs about eight times faster so which
is which is great
um and that's something that that we
have access to to run uh to run locally
um so what this is doing is it's it's
similar to what parallel map
does it splits up this list into uh into
chunks
uh but instead of running each chunk on
a um on
a separate core it runs each chunk uh in
a separate
remote uh remote batch job so up here
we had submitted just one job that has
some arbitrary code in it and it runs it
here we're giving it a list so my
function here just squares a a number
it's trivial a trivial example and i
have a list of 100 elements here so
what it's going to do here is it splits
up it's going to uh by default it
automatically figures out if
it picks a a method to split up this
list the default is that it
it basically splits it it takes the
square root of the length of the list
and
tries to have roughly that many jobs uh
child jobs
so uh so this remote batch submit
function here has returned
a what's called an array job uh an array
job is different from
what's here which is a what we did
before which is a single job
an array job uh contains multiple child
jobs uh so that was the that's that's
the splitting up that i mentioned so
here right it split up our list of 100
elements
into 10 uh child jobs each child job
contains
10 elements so get 100 so it's it's 10
by 10
10 by 10 matrix uh so to speak that
that's the topology of this
um so uh uh so i'm actually going to run
this
one more time and um just because i want
to be able to show something in the
middle of how it's running
so it has to uh takes a few seconds to
upload all of the
the input information okay so let's get
this visualization again
um or the second visualization rather um
so we have we have this which is that's
just uh showing how this
how our list of 100 elements got got
chunked up got split into
uh into uh into child jobs um now this
is a dynamic visualization each of these
cells
represents one of those child jobs and
this is going to update
live and show the status of each of
those child jobs as the
uh as it progresses um so right now
they're all in the runnable state which
is
something on aws batch it just basically
means it's it's
it's uh it's it's going to start running
soon
um basically um so soon this should uh
some of these or at least some of them
one or some should turn uh purple or
green which indicate uh here we go
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna go grab the
results
um uh right now because i wanna be able
to
there we go uh
just want to see if i hopefully i didn't
miss the chance
because what i want to show is what
happens when i get these results while
some of the jobs have completed but not
all of them because that's a that's an
important
uh important thing here um to
demonstrate
um so sorry did you have a question uh
no actually the question i was going to
ask is what happens if you
try to get results when before the
computation finishes so
uh continue excellent okay great uh
we're we're thinking on the same track
here then
um so the really cool thing about um
about remote batch map submit and what
makes it um
uh really powerful for very large scale
jobs is that you can obtain
partial results so uh so if some of
some of your child jobs have finished
but not others you can get the results
of
uh from just the just the child job so
just the chunks of your big input list
that have completed um and this is this
is this is valuable for
for two reasons uh basically one um you
can uh
it gives you you you have a chance to
figure out if you're if you've submitted
a giant job that will
take hours and hours to ride across uh
many many even hundreds of
of cpu cores um you can get uh you could
you have
you get a chance to see uh when just
just some of your initial child jobs
have finished
if something's wrong if if there's
something wrong with uh with your output
um that indicates an error in your code
uh you have a chance to
catch that before you've gone through
and run uh run through your
your entire list so um so you so that's
something that we couldn't do
up here with our single job we we have
to we we've submitted it and then we're
just
we're we have to wait until until it's
done and if there was an
error in the code uh that caused the
results to be useless
well right tough
um down here um i didn't actually quite
get to see this uh because it looks like
these
these had all succeeded let me just run
it sorry one more time and see let's see
if we can catch this
um but basically so we get our results
in this sparse array which which uh is a
wolfram language object that represents
a an array a list in which only some of
the elements are present
uh so it's a memory efficient way of
representing a a sparse array
um so what what's gonna happen here is
looks like this is submitted
let's just see if we can uh we can get
these um but okay it looks like none of
them yeah
um so if i look at this actually if i
look at the actual contents of this it's
just an array of 100 elements
all of which are missing none of them
are none of them are have been populated
uh yet um so i'm going to try this
one more time it's it's it's kind of
hard it's like a moving target
trying to catch this and demonstrate the
behavior that i'm
that i'm looking for but uh if this
doesn't work here i can just copy over i
have an example result uh
that i computed earlier and this is this
is exactly what you would see if i if i
caught the job at just the right time
so in here there are some stretches of
of ten or uh of ten elements um that are
present because the child jobs that were
responsible for those chunks completed
while others hadn't hadn't yet completed
um and then the other reason i mentioned
two reasons why this is really valuable
uh the other is that if some of your
child jobs fail for whatever reason
maybe something
uh error in your code that only happened
in some cases or maybe something out of
your control like the kernel crashed
right um if if so if some of your child
jobs fail and you you've lost
those results but you've only lost the
results for those child jobs so
if if one percent of your uh of your of
your 1 000 child jobs fail if 10 of them
fail
you've only lost the results uh for
those for those 10 child jobs so you can
just go rerun
just those parts of the list to get to
get your um
to get the correct results uh you don't
have to go if not like normally again
i can contrast with this example up here
if if one of these iterations of the
table had caused the kernel to crash i
would have lost all of my results
right um uh and and again if this is
taking like a couple hours that's
that's a lot of my my time that i've
that that's that's uh
now gone to waste if i've if if one
error has caused the whole thing to fail
while here one error the like the sort
of the blast radius of the
of an error in your code or of a kernel
crash is just the child job that
that was containing it and the other
child jobs are entirely unaffected right
um so uh so some of these missings could
have represented child jobs that have
failed
but i've only lost the results from
those jobs i still have everything else
and then bob is the whole uh job is is
complete um the whole array job so all
of the child jobs
i can get uh uh evaluation results as a
uh as a full dance array instead of a
sparse array
which just contains um all of the
results
uh from all of the child jobs gotcha and
that should be a
there we go so that's a lot of work to
square all the numbers
but of course it's just an example well
you know the computer can do it uh
faster than we can regardless so uh
right um
yeah so we're uh we're running a little
low on time but let's go
real quickly through um your safe
cracker example because i do think it's
kind of a cool little
uh demonstration of how much
time you can save on a larger project
like this absolutely
yeah so we'll we'll just breeze through
this so i'll very quickly explain sort
of
the setting here i have this this puzzle
which i think i got at
a yard sale um which is it's this wooden
thing and i have pictures here which are
much better than what show up on my
camera
uh my webcam um so it's these there are
five of these uh wooden discs and you
you rotate them
and the goal is to make each of these
these columns these sectors here
the numbers in the sector should add up
to 50 which is the number written at the
center here
um so uh i uh being a programmer i
didn't want to
solve this by hand using using my brain
if i can get a computer of course
um so i did and i solved it it's i used
a very brute force approach which is
just
sort of digitally rotating all of the
rings and trying every possible comment
combination until i find one uh that
works um
so i'm not going to show the code to do
this because it's not not uh not
particularly relevant here but and i'm
not even gonna run it because it takes
like uh 20 seconds or so i don't want to
don't
don't want to take up 20 seconds of your
time um
so this is running in serial not in
parallel or anything just a single core
so tried tried all of the possible
combinations which with
this one which is five rings and 16
sectors it's it's
16 to the uh to the five minus one so 16
to the four possible combinations which
is like
65 000 uh i think um
yeah okay 65 um uh
so and then i have this this what's the
uh the result and so this number here is
just a sort of
uh that represents how many how many
rotations you have to make of the
of the initial configuration to get the
the correct result
and i'm trying out this result here we
can we can we can check these and
you can just trust me that that each of
these sectors adds up to 50
or those watching the video can can uh
can check themselves if they'd like to
um so this one's this is easy to run
locally this doesn't need to run in
in the cloud um uh this is fine but uh
what i wanted to do is try generating my
own puzzle so i generate
a a bigger one so i did one that has
seven rings instead of five
um so it's uh it's that sixty five
thousand times sixteen
times another sixteen uh possible
combination so it's up to something like
16 million
uh possible combinations and this
becomes a little uncomfortable to uh so
i just have functions that generate
a random uh uh a random like initial
condition of this
uh of this of this puzzle here um for
that number of
rings and sectors uh and then another
function that scrambles it so
uh so um so i have i have my the correct
solution and then the scrambled solution
then i want to work back
backwards from the scrambled solution to
find the correct solution
uh so running this serially locally just
on one core
takes almost two hours uh uh to run
that's just i'm a single
core on my desktop uh i can run it in
parallel on my desktop which has six
cores
which brings it down to 18 minutes which
is which is not bad i think
um yeah but uh using remote batch submit
i can take
i can take advantage of more cores than
i have locally on my
on my computer i can use that i
mentioned that 96 core
ec2 instance i can i can use that that's
the one i'm using here
um so i'll go ahead and i'll go ahead
and run this just in case we have time
to see the result it should take about
about two minutes but i can just right
now show the result that i have from
earlier
um so it takes it takes about two
minutes to run uh
to run this job or a minute and 40
seconds uh to do the actual computation
across those
96 cores in comparison to 18 minutes in
parallel locally
and almost two hours in serial locally
and then i've got this i've got this
number which is my
sort of the that is the answer that i'm
trying to get and i can check it out
here and again you can trust me that all
of
the columns the sectors should add up to
uh to 50.
yeah i mean doing uh what almost almost
10 million rotations in less than two
minutes seems
uh pretty impressive yeah and also i
should mention the code that i've
written is not particularly optimized i
didn't take the time to
eke out every little bit of performance
that i could have using the wolfram
language i just wanted
an example uh nice example to show here
sure
very quick example um and i know
you said that right now we you support
uh
we support charity engine and aws
uh could you just just real briefly uh
tell me a little bit about what charity
engine is
right so so charity engine is is an
interesting
um charity engine is an interesting
service um basically
instead of running on computers that
charity engine or
instead of running on computers that
amazon uh owns themselves
which is the case with amazon ec2 using
aws batch um we're running on on
computers of
uh of volunteers who have signed up to
to help charity engine
run jobs that have been submitted to
them submitted to charity engine and
uh often those these these are um these
jobs are
our non-commercial things they're
they're uh like academic research uh
research projects that just need
need access to a a very large uh a large
network of computers to do some
distributed computation um so when i
submit a job to charity engine it's
running on the on the
usually a i think a regular desktop
computer of a regular person who is a
a volunteer uh with the charity engine
uh service
um so i'm i'm not gonna run this example
here because it takes a little bit the
latency is involved with charity
engine are longer than those for for aws
batch um but i just have an example here
showing that the
the interface is exactly the same ws
batch i just
the second argument here is my code to
run and it gets run and i get the result
so you can it's actually very easy to
switch between providers if you
if you start off on aws batch and then
want to switch to charity engine
uh for whatever reason maybe it's
cheaper or you have a larger job that
makes more sense on charity engine
it's very easy to switch uh switch to a
different environment um
and and keep your existing remote batch
submit code
sure yeah and it makes sense that uh you
know in the future
when more support is added people will
be able to
sort of pick and choose depending on
what providers they have available to
themselves
absolutely excellent well thank you very
much for
uh explaining everything here about
remote batch submit
and charity engine um yeah you're
welcome i'm sorry that we went a little
bit over time
no problem at all uh it's good
information to have and uh
you know thank you we'll talk to you
later yes see you brian
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more on the wolfram research
youtube channel or see what else is new
at wolfram.com